hey everyone
welcome to another video by simpler i am
sure you must have watched our previous
videos on uipath if you haven't watched
them already
i would suggest you to go through easy
tutorials on every topic
on uipath uipath is a well known rpa
tool
it has grown in popularity over the
years and it is now used by
organizations all over the world
uipath assists business in successfully
automating their business process
if you are planning to attend an
interview for an rpa or ui part
developer role
here is a comprehensive list of most
frequently asked ui path interview
questions with answers
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and clicked on the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
what is ui path this question looks
simple
but people most of the time end up
giving wrong definition
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks
into automated process what are the
different components in ui
ui path consists of three components
mainly ui path studio
ui patch studio is a user friendly
interface that allows users to visually
plan
and design various automation process
through diagrams using the drag and drop
functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks that must
be completed
uipath robot after you have built your
process
the next move is to put into action in
the uipath studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
strategies into tasks which are then
executed
these robots are used to assign various
tasks and carry them out in the same
manner as humans
but without human interference when
given an operation occurs on the
computer
they program uipath robots to begin
executing task automatically
uipath orchestrator the orchestrator is
a web-based application in uipath
it has features for deploying monitoring
scheduling
and controlling automated bots and
process it's a centralized forum for
managing and maintaining all software
bots
what are the different workflows in
uipath
sequences a sequence is a small type of
project
that is best suited for linear process
it enables developers to transition from
one activity to another easily
they can be reused numerous times
flowchart it can be used for large or
small
projects that help in development of
complex business
and connecting activities in a variety
of ways
flowcharts assist in the presentation of
multiple branches of logical operators
state machine a state machine is a
machine that uses a certain number of
states
for automation during execution it will
only change states if an action is
performed on it
let's look at the next question what is
a ui path robot
the robot is a ui path execution agent
allowing you to run process created in
the studio
in order to execute process robots must
be connected to the orchestrator
or licensed locally what are the
different components of uipath robot
service the robot service is the primary
controller for all operations
it communicates with studio the robot
agent and the robot command line
interface
by an inter-process communication
channel to receive and process
information
executor the robot executor is the
component that is directly responsible
for process execution
the robot service creates a robot
executor instance every time a job is
started
command line interface the robot command
line interface is a console application
that starts jobs and waits for the
results
uipath assistant is a tool designed
specifically to improve the user's
interaction
with our robots from the comfort of the
desktop
it is where users can easily access
manage and run
automation with a few clicks
what is the difference between attended
and unattended robot
attended robots are supervised robots
that humans operate
they work on the same workstation as a
human user and is triggered by user
events
unattended robots unattended robots are
those that do not require human
supervision to perform
tasks they run in virtual environments
without human control
and can automate any number of process
what are the features of uipath drag and
drop workflow
the uipath user will develop visual
process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace
then with the user interface properties
they can transform these process steps
into a visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool
to build web-based or application
workflow
record and playback the user can use
this function
to record actions and transform them
into an automated process series
inbuilt activities in uipath ui path
comes with over 300 built-in activities
covering a wide range of process
automation and application
integrated design task you can find
these activities in activities pane
which covers most design tasks such as
data extraction data entry and
automation
advanced scraping options scraping data
from web pages
and applications is more accessible with
ui path screen scraping
furthermore the data scraping wizard
helps in the scraping of data
with a repetitive structure scraping
solution works flawlessly with any
program including dotnet java flash
pdf legacy and sap high security and
robustness
you can create super smart durable
robots with uipath
visual canvas everyone in the company
can use these boards
uipath offers high security auto login
functionality to run the bots
and operates with a locked screen
allowing automated process to run in
complete privacy
what are the different recording options
in uipath
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task
and is commonly used to develop each
activity's complete selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions as well as
application development
web recording web recording is a
standard tool for viewing and recording
web activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
what is a manage package in ui path
the package manager functionality allows
to download activities packages
libraries frameworks wrappers and others
and view and update the ones already
installed for the project
and add and remove it it displays the
list of available packages per feed
and a list of dependencies for the
current project
the manage package windows always opens
with the project dependencies list
how to publish a project in uipath
to publish a project in uipath first
create a new project
then in the design ribbon tab click
publish the publish window
will open in the package properties tab
enter the name for package then click
next
in the publish options tab select the
location where you want to publish your
project
and finally the information dialog box
displays
so let's see a demo how
is it done so let's jump in the ui patch
studio
so here we are in ui patch studio
let's open our workflow
i'll drag and drop a simple message box
just to show
enter a message say
hey
so i have created a simple workflow just
to show you how to publish
project in uipath
so here you can see the publish option
once you have created the project go to
the ribbon tab
and click on the publish
when you click the publish window opens
here you can change the package name if
you want you can see the version
new version package icon and release
notes
so let's click on next
here you will get the custom url where
you want to publish to
then click on publish
here you go you can see publishing
package
so a info dialog box appears project
published successfully
if you want you can copy to the
clipboard so this is how the project is
published in the ui path
what is data scraping and screen
scraping
data scraping is the process of
extracting structured data from a
browser
application or document and saving it to
a database
or a dot csv file or even an excel
spreadsheet
screen scraping methods are activities
that allow data to be extracted from a
specific ui
element or document such as a dot pdf
file
explain the different types of
automation in uipath
excel automation excel automation is a
useful
tool for sorting deleting retrieving and
analyzing data
it is simple to migrate and integrate
data
into platforms studio x has a strong
integration with microsoft excel and
ships with several activities
that automate excel task
mail automation enables task automation
with emails from the outlook desktop
application
gmail and outlook 365. add the
activities that use data from the
account
inside the resource activity after
adding the account to the automation
as a resource using a used outlook 365.
use gmail
or use desktop outlook app activity
word automation in the word automation
add the word document to be worked on by
using a
word file activity and then add the word
activities to automate within the use
word file
powerpoint automation powerpoint
automation allows the user to automate
the most common task in powerpoint
presentation
at the presentation to work with the use
powerpoint presentation activity
and then inside the use powerpoint
presentation add the presentation
activities to automate
file automation it refers to the
automation of task performed on your
computer
with files and folders such as creating
copying or renaming files and folders
studio x includes several activities
that automate tasks that you perform
with files and folders
csv automation in csv automation
add the csv activities inside the use
excel file activity
where the excel file is defined to move
data between csv
and excel
explain a few read and write activities
read range read range reads the values
of an
excel range and stores in a data table
variable
read cell reads the values of an excel
cell and stores in a variable
read csv reads all entries from a
specified csv file
write range writes data from a data
table variable
to a spreadsheet write cell
writes a value or formula into a
specified spreadsheet cell
write csv overwrites a specified data
table to a csv file
what is an excel application scope
excel application scope opens an excel
workbook
and sets the scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed
the specified workbook and excel
application are closed
what is an orchestrator uipath
orchestrator is a web application
that orchestrates the execution of
repetitive process
it manages the creation monitoring
scheduling and controlling of bots and
process
it can manage the entire robot fleet
name some orchestrator capabilities
provisioning provisioning establishes
and maintains the connection between the
robots and the web application
deployment ensures that it delivers the
correct package versions to the assigned
robots for execution
configuration looks after the
maintenance and delivery of robot
environments and process configuration
queues ensures that it automatically
distributes the workload across robots
monitoring manages user permissions and
keeps track of robot
recognition details logging
logs are stored and indexed in an sql
database
explain process job asset and queue
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages
managing existing process and keep all
of your process up to date with the
latest package version
jobs on an uipath robot a job represents
the execution of procedure
it can start the execution of job in
either attended or unattended mode
cues a queue is a storage container that
can accommodate an infinite number of
objects multiple types of data such as
invoice
information or customer data are stored
in queue objects
other systems such as sap or salesforce
are used to process this data
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials
that can be used through several
automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
how to connect a robot to the
orchestrator
step 1 open uipath assistant
step 2 sign in the uipath orchestrator
step 3 create a tenant step 4
connect the robot to the orchestrator
and step 5
check the status it shows connected and
licensed
so let's see a demo of how to do this so
let's jump into the uipath studio
open you step one open uipath assistant
so we'll open uipath assistant
after opening uipath assistant login to
the uipath orchestrator
so go to the browser
go to the browser and type
platform.uipart.com
this will take to the uipath website
so sign in if you're new to this if you
don't have the account
then you can enter all the details and
login
since i've already created an account
i'll sign in
after logging in the uipath orchestrator
go to the admin
here you can create a new tenant you can
add a tenant here and create a new
tenant since i have already created a
tenant
named admin so after creating a tenant
connect the robot to the orchestrator
go to the ui path assistant
go to preferences go to preferences
go to orchestrator settings
here you can see the status it is
offline click on the sign in button
once you click on the sign in button
allow this open uipath
here you can see it is connecting
and you can see it is connected and
licensed
so the ui path robot is now connected
with the orchestrator
what is a tenant context and folder
context
in tenant context to view and control
tenant level entities in the
orchestrator
pick tenant from the sidebar menu with
only one instance of the orchestrator
multi-tenancy allows isolating data
for the folder context from the sidebar
menu pick any available folder to view
and control the entities within the
data folder
so i'll show you let's go to the
orchestrator
so let's go to the orchestrator
here you can see this is the tenant
context
to view and control the tenant level
entities in orchestrator you can pick
the tenant
from the sidebar menu from the sidebar
menu pick
any available folder so these are the
folders pick any available folder
to view and control the entities within
that folder
so this is with respect to the folder
context
what is an re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
it allows to handle even the most
complex business situations
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices
for logging exception management
application initialization
and other areas what are the features of
re framework
settings during the initialization phase
of several process
some configuration settings and
configuration values
are frequently read like urls to a web
application
orchestrator queue names and default
logging messages
logging the built-in locking mechanism
is another helpful feature of the
framework the majority of the system's
workflows
use log message activities to output
information
about what is happening at each
execution stage
business exception if the issue is with
the data or any underlying business
requirement
the system skips the transaction and
moves on to the next
search exceptions are known as business
exceptions
application exception if the issue can
be resolved by restarting applications
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again
search exceptions are known as
application exceptions
how to merge two excel files into a
single excel file
first we need to create a sequence after
creating a sequence
we need a few activities like read csv
activity
assign activity data table activity and
write cs file activity
so we'll drag and drop all these
activities and do the process
then we'll run the sequence and see the
output
so let's jump into the ui path studio
and start with the
workflow
so we are in the uipath studio i have
already created a sequence you can go to
new and create a sequence
or press ctrl n
so after starting a sequence first we
will drag and drop
read csv activity
since we are using two excel files so we
need to read csv activity
we will drag and drop another read csv
activity
so we will select the location of the
first excel file
select the first excel file
i'll show you both the excel files which
we are merging
so this is the first excel file so it
has
five rows five names
so we'll this is the first excel file
and
this is the second excel files this
excel file has five different names
and the other excel file has five
different rows
so these are the two excel files will
merge both these excel files
into a single new excel file
so we'll close this excel files
so in the first read csv activity we
have
copied the location of the first excel
file in the output 2
we will select this and create a
variable right click and create a
variable
and let's say name the variable as sl
underscore
5 1
we have named the variable
okay now we'll go to another read csv
file
and select the location of the second
file
so i have downloaded this sample excel
files from the internet
just for the demo right click and create
a variable
let's say name this variable as sl
underscore file two
so now that we have dragged and dropped
to read csv activities
now next we need assign activity
so drag and drop assign activity
so assign activity has two parameters as
you can see
two and enter a vb expression
in the two parameter in this right click
and create a variable
and name the variable let's say
merged essay
after naming the variable enter an
expression here
so enter the expression as sl underscore
file 1 which is the variable for file 1
select this and enter the expression dot
clone
what this clone function does is the
clone function creates a new data table
with the same structure but does not
copy the data
so we are creating a new excel file that
is the third file in which we are
merging
the data tables of both the excel file
so the third excel file which we are
creating
will have the same structure as the file
one so
this clone function creates a third
excel file with the same structure as
the file one
so it's showing an error so select this
assign
let's go to variables here you can see
variable type string
change it to system dot data dot data
table
and here you go the error is gone
okay so now we have dragged and dropped
assign activity
the next activity which we need is merge
data table activity
let's search for merge
data table activity drag-and-drop
modulatable activity we need to merge
data table activity since we
have two excel files select the first
merge data table activity
go to the destination and enter the
destination
which is the variable which we created
in the assign activity
the merged is so
enter this and enter the source file
that is the variable which you created
in file one that is sl underscore
file one similarly similarly
go to merge data table
and enter the same destination
but here the source will be the second
file
okay now that we have dragged and
dropped too much data tables the next
activity
we need is a write csv file
so we'll search for write csv file
after dragging and dropping write csv
activity go to file path
and create a file create a file say
one will name it as file
three
safety file
now that we have created the file we
will write
from the data table that is we need to
copy the merge data table
so we'll enter
now that we have finished the program
the file is created
let's save and run it
process execution has started and ended
so let's go to the file
so this is the file which we created
let's open this file
and here you can see both the excel
files have been merged into a single
excel file
let's go to the next question how to
send a file over at
mail so first create a sequence
and create a file after you have created
a file
drag and drop get password activity
then drag and drop a smtp mail message
activity
so basically these two activities are
used to send a file over
me then run the sequence so we'll
jump into the ui path studio and see so
this was the previous question which we
answered how to merge two excel files so
the same file we will send it over and
mail so we need a get password activity
so we'll drag and drop a get password
activity
so if you go to the properties section
enter the password
to whichever mail you are sending riffs
file enter the password of that
mail id
after entering the password in the
result go and create a variable
so that password is stored in that
variable so name the variable
say anything any randomly so i've named
the variable
after after this you need
a smtp mail message activity
so drag and drop send smtp mail message
in smtp mail message under the
properties pane
under the host enter the port value
for the port number which is 587
after entering the port number go to the
server
and enter it as smtp.gmail.com
okay now after entering the email id
go to your email and enter your email id
to which you want to send this file
don't forget to use double quotes
otherwise it will show an error
enter the password so we had showed the
password in the variable
say sss so
we'll write that
so after that enter the email id here
under the two option
and enter the subject say it has demo
since we are showing a demo
we will enter the subject as demo this
is the this subject and body
is the subject and body of the mail
now let's attach the file which we have
created
copy the file location so we'll go to
the file
and copy this file location
after attaching the file
let's save android
the process has started and the process
has ended
here you can see in the the output has
started and the process has ended
let's go over the mail and check if we
have received
here we go we have received the file
let's open the file
and here you go the same this is the
same file which had
merged the data so the file has been
sent over the
mail one thing you have to keep in mind
when you use the get password activity
go to your google account
in the security section
go to this secure app access and turn it
on
you have to turn it on to receive the
file over and mail
explain the different states and
transitions in re framework
there are four key states in re
framework
the first state is initial state this is
the point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings
and runs application test to ensure that
all of the prerequisites for the process
start are met
next we have get transaction state this
state retrieves the next transaction
object this can be a queue item or a
collection item
transaction items are queue items by
default
but this can be modified to meet your
needs this is also when the developer
can set the condition
to exit the state when there are no
items to process
process transaction state for the
transaction item obtained in previous
step
it performs actions logic in various
application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item available
end process state the procedure is
completed
and the applications open during
automations are closed
in the end process state let's
jump into the ui path studio and see
the different transitions in robotic
enterprise framework
so this is the robotic enterprise
framework this is the
initialization state the first state so
it has two
transitions system error that is system
exception
and successful when it shows system
exception when a system error is not
nothing
it gets transition to the end process
suppose if you have an application
exception during the initialization
phase
and we don't have enough details to
start a process then as a result we are
going to end process state to wrap it up
and the successful is when a system
error is nothing
it gets transition to get transaction
state
if during initialization we have no
error then
it goes to the get transaction data
the get transaction data has two
transitions
no data and new transaction no data is
when if the transaction item is nothing
then we are at the end of our data
collection so it goes to the end process
and in new transaction if the
transaction item contains data then it
processes it
the process transaction data has three
transitions
success business exception and system
exception
success is when if the condition is
business rule exception is nothing
and system error is nothing then the
transition to get transaction data
if there is a business rule exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transaction
and rule exception is if the business
rule exception is not nothing then it
gets transaction to the
get transaction data and the end process
does not have any transition since the
end process is the final state
so there are no transitions what is a
g-suite activity
the uipath g-suite activity package
helps in the automation of google
workspace applications
such as google calendar google drive
google sheets gmail google docs
you can create and modify google
calendar events
manage google drive files read and send
gmail messages
and create new google sheets
spreadsheets and google documents with
the google g-suite activity package
what are selectors and wildcards in ui
path
wildcards are the symbols that enable
you to replace zero or
multiple characters in a string this can
be quite useful when dealing with
dynamically changing attributes in a
selector
selectors uipath studio uses what we
call selectors
this store the attributes of graphical
user interface element
and its parents in the shape of an xml
fragment
the selectorates in the automatic
generation of the selection
by utilizing wildcards
what is a machine explain standard
machine and machine template
the machine page allows you to provision
and manages machines to use them to
register robots with orchestrator
it displays the types of machine that we
currently in use
it enables you to design your machine
whether standard or template
standard machine it should be used when
the name of the machine on which you
want to define robots
is the same every time you connect to it
you define the machine once
and then you can connect to as many
robots as you want from the robots page
machine template it should be used
whenever the name of the machine on
which you want to define
robot changes you represent this entity
once and then you use a unique active
directory username to connect to any
number of attended floating robots
explain delay do if and switch
activities in uipath
the delay activity allows you to pause
the automation for a specified amount of
time
this activity is beneficial in projects
that require precise timing
such as waiting for a specific
application to start
or for some information to be processed
before using it in the another activity
the do activity allows you to run a
specific piece of automation
while the condition is met the project
exits the loop when the specified
condition is no longer completed
this activity can be used to iterate
through all the array elements
or execute a specific action multiple
times
if activity the if activity includes a
statement as well as two conditions
if the statement is true the first
condition is executed
if the statement is false the second
condition is executed
if activities can be used to make
decision based on variable values
switch activity the switch activity
allows you to choose one of the several
options
based on the value of specified
expression the switch activity uses an
integer argument by default
but you can change it in the properties
panel under the type argument list
the switch activity can be used to
categorize data based on predefined
number of cases
how to create chart in excel
step 1 create a new sequence go to the
ui path studio
and create a new sequence and then drag
and drop the following activities
to create a chart we need to use excel
application scope
create table activity and bar chart and
pie chart activity
depending on which type of charts you
want to create
then at last after completing then run
the sequence
we will see a demo of this in the uipath
studio
how to upload a file on drive so create
a new sequence
and drag and drop a g-suite application
then inside g-suite application
drag and drop upload file activity fill
in the details
and finally run the suite let's go and
see a demo
to how to create charts in excel file
and how to upload a file on your drive
so let's jump into the ui path studio
this is the excel file which i have
created
it has all the number of cases in this
five states
in the year 2021 the month of jan feb
march and
april all this record i have taken it
from a website called
prsindia dot org
so i have two sheets sheet one and sheet
two
so let's jump into the uipath studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages
installed one is the uipath
excel activities package the other one
is uipath g suite dot activities
this activity this package is used for
drive
top load on the drive then
the other package is balareva excel
activities
this package is used for bar graph and
pie chart
so after installing these three
packages we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence 2
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is it opens an
excel workbook and sets the scope for
excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and the excel
applications
are closed when the workbook application
variable is specified in the output
workbook activities field the
spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop create table
activity
so by default we have sheet 1 and
enter the range so the range is
in this excel sheet the range is from a1
to f5 so enter the range
for this we need to enter the file path
so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file we have
entered the
entire table name say
number of cases
so once this much is done next we'll
drag and drop a
bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scope and select the file path
so select the file
so select the file select this cell
range
that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
a1 to s5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
barge tag 3d clustered 3d stand whatever
is required
for now we will select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and select show value
if you want to show percentage you can
select percentage
and select show legend and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want so i'll keep the size
as 350
to 350 you can change the width
so the bar chart is done and you can
enter the sheet which sheet are you
using so it's sheet one
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
show legend
select show value
and select the sheet which you are we'll
select the sheet 2
so done so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive
so we'll select this option upload file
select the file
so we have selected define so select the
destination folder
for that go to your google drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this url
till here not the entire copy this
and go to your ui patch studio and paste
it in the destination folder
delete double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error
oh we have forgotten to use a g-suit
application
this can be only used inside a g-suite
application
so drag and drop a g-suite application
and inside g-suite application
will write this so there is god
so we'll run the file now we'll save it
and run
you can see the file is getting run
so the execution is ended we will
navigate to the drive
so here you can see the file is
successfully uploaded
will open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one with the values
number of values and each state was and
for sheet2
we created a pie chart so here you go
here you can see the puzzle
if you have any doubt any queries please
don't
hesitate to ask in the comment section
we will try to answer
all of your questions so with that we
have reached the end of this video
like and share it if you found it
interesting thank you for being here
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here